1,000 years into the future humans might
look like
this this is Mindy a model that shows
what we humans might look like in the
year
3000 equipped with a hunched over back
Claws and a smaller brain Mindy has
adapted this way primarily due to
technology and cell phones but this is
just a start of a potential evolutionary
journey of the human
body Let's Travel 1 million years into
the future to see the even crazier ways
our bodies will
evolve super strength giant eyes and
edited genes are all things you might
see later in this episode but why are we
getting all these traits anyway well
more on that in a second but for now
let's check in and see what the next
phase of evolution is for
humans 5,000 years into the
future okay we're now several thousand
years into the future and in many ways
humans would look relatively similar to
how we do now yeah if we look 5,000
years into the past from where we are
today well humans look basically the
same the main differences are that well
we're now healthier taller and stronger
this is primarily due to how our diet
Healthcare and lifestyle have changed
throughout the
centuries this is speculation but you
can assume that a lot will have happened
5,000 years into the future changes that
include space travel and massive
advancements in technology and
Ai and how we look all depends on where
humans decide to live in the
future if Humanity becomes an
Interstellar civilization well it might
look like this
and if we stay on Earth and go all in on
AI well humans might look more like this
so we'll explore a couple of options as
we move through the years the
generations of humans who decide to go
to Mars will notice the most significant
changes Mars's lower gravity would lead
to less bone density and muscle mass but
the change in gravity might also lead to
increased height and longer limbs
and there'll be a lot more changes
coming up but for now let's take another
jump into the future and check on some
other options for human
evolution you know if you're wondering
how we found out about some of the
information in this video well you got
to check out curiosity stream we looked
at a couple of documentaries to try and
get a handle on the future of humanity
my favorite was one called how to build
a human and it explores the technology
and ethics of building a human AI hybrid
and how that may be closer than you
might think then I ended up watching a
bunch of other docs on a ton of
different subjects space Humanity even
military history all accessible on my TV
my tablet and my phone if you like what
if you're going to love curiosity stream
they got something for everyone and new
content every week and the plans start
at just $5 a month if you want to watch
awesome docks and help out the channel
well check out curiositystream.com
whatat ifshow or scan the QR code on
screen use the promo code what if show
for 25% off your annual
subscription 25,000 years into the
future it's safe to say that technology
will play a heavy role in how humans
evolve traveling 25,000 years into the
future well you might decide to have a
designer baby instead of creating life
naturally and leaving so many things to
chance you would select various traits
for who you want your baby to be you
could choose physical characteristics
like hair and eye color and much more
essential features like the ability to
avoid certain diseases and
allergies in a way this is already
happening today but in the future it'll
be more advanced and accessible it's
also likely that humans will begin to
fuse with technology becoming cyborg
like
beings think neural links robot limbs
and sensory
enhancements imagine having a chip in
your brain that's equipped with an AI
that provides you with any answer you
need humans will have all these
cybernetic enhancements that will make
them smarter stronger and able to live
longer 100,000 years into the
future one of the ways which we can see
how much humans have evolved is by
looking at our faces and heads as you
see here in 100,000 years our eyes and
heads will be significantly
larger this will be due to multiple
reasons one of them being that we'll be
living in different environments like
space our larger eyes will allow us to
see better in low light environments
it'll also help protect our eyes from
the cosmic rays found in space on Mars
along with bones becoming less dense and
limbs continuing to get longer residents
there will need to develop some new Sur
survival traits to last this long as
Humanity has developed on Mars over the
generations well they've been
experiencing tons of radiation in their
environment that's thanks to the lack of
an atmosphere on the red planet over
time humanity there has slowly adapted
to this new way of life but the
radiation levels are so harsh that they
likely haven't adapted enough to live
comfortably one of the problems with
evolution is that it's incredibly slow
slow seeing significant change in our
bodies can take millions of years so to
fix that we'll need to make some changes
ourselves you'll see what I mean as we
continue on to our 1 million year
mark
250,000 years into the
future yeah Humanity was tired of
waiting and waiting for changes in
evolution to happen so they've decided
to do it themselves we've been altering
our body with technology for hundreds of
thousands of years at this point but now
we're going to take it to another level
yeah instead of adding some sort of
enhancement to our bodies well we'll now
alter our DNA with Advanced genetic
manipulation scientists are already
experimenting with this technology but
250,000 years from now well you can bet
the science will be Advanced beyond
belief scientists will be able to alter
edit and even add different genetic
mutations both before people are born
and
after in the case of our Colony on Mars
well people on that planet could alter
their genes so that the radiation isn't
as harmful to their bodies and that's
just the start eventually we'll alter
our genes to produce all sorts of insane
attributes you could be brilliant have
super strength or be immune to every
disease as Humanity un locks this new
era of human evolution things are about
to get even
better by the way are you wondering
where we've been getting all these crazy
video ideas lately well they come from
our patreon we've got an exclusive
Discord where members get
front-of-the-line access to talk about
the wh if ideas they want made sign up
and maybe we'll create your next
idea 500,000 years into the
future okay it's been another 250,000
years Humanity has been playing around
with this Gene editing thing and it's
gotten pretty ridiculous scientists have
managed to combine parts of lizard dna
with our human DNA this has allowed us
to regrow our Limbs and grow new organs
if we need them also along with the help
of technology and Gene editing humans
are more intelligent than ever we can
now naturally have any appearance we
want this might sound kind of scary but
Gene editing like this will likely be
essential for us to survive in new
environments like space and our evolving
Earth 1 million years into the
future so remember the humans back on
Earth the ones who were adding tons of
cybernetic enhancements to their bodies
yeah they've continued to do that along
with tons of Gene editing and the people
in space have been doing the same thing
but as we've been progressing through
these 1 million years well the
environments on Earth and Mars have been
very different and because of these
different environments the humans living
on these planets would have different
needs and desires for the types of
bodies they
want remember evolution is all about
lifestyle and environment that's why
Mindy at the start looked the way she
did it's possible that the humans living
on these two planets would be so
different that they'd essentially be two
completely separate species sort of like
50,000 years ago when there were humans
on Earth at the same time as
neandertals but regardless of how
they're different it's likely that both
types of future humans will be the most
advanced species ever seen we'll live
longer maybe forever be smarter than
ever and be ready to take on whatever
challenges the future holds speaking of
the future at this point humanity is
likely in a type two or maybe even a
type three
civilization but what happens after
that well that sounds like a story for
another what
if